今回は天才小学生がロブロックスにはまりすぎて秘密の現部屋を作ったり友達と喧嘩をしたりして大騒ぎに果たしてどうなっちゃうのか。
お前自中に何ゲ
バンカラジオ
お邪魔します。フォナやろうぜ。
すごい。
何やってんの?ロブロックスだよ。え、知らないの?
何それ?つまんなそう。やってみなよ。うん。ゲームを作ったり、誰かが作ったゲームで遊べるアプリ。今はイタリアンプレイノットを盗めってのが流行ってるんだよ。
ゴー。
革命だ。柔度の高い石ラブり。そしてこのスルと達成感全てが面白い。
はい。それではここの授業を始めます。
お前は恋をしている。
ブパピ。
え?
お前の時に何ゲームやって?
俺のロブロックスが。く。あれはダンボールで作ったラビ。これで警戒を解いて遊んでやる。
え、屋根す、僕より盗むのうますぎてレベルマックスじゃん。すごい。僕天才ですから。
てんてん天才。やねやねやね。すっけ
おい
だからゲームやるやんて行ってくれ。
おきいんだ。ナイスナイス。
イエー。
このゲームにはランキングがあって
1番レアなキャラを集めた人が1
位になれるんだ。俺も1位になりたいな。
ねえね、俺の見て。昨日朝まで頑張ってゲットしたシークレットアの落カラーチャー。
すげえ。えーイ。
え?何してんの?
えーイ。
え、おい、盗むな。えーい。おい、待て。え、待て。えーい。ねえ、なんで盗むの?返してよ。僕が一生懸命頑張ったやつじゃん。そういうゲームだろ。ねえ、返してよ。聞いたが容人なのが悪いんだよ。じゃあね。ねえ、返して。頑張り。ああ。
おっと。高がゲームで泣かないで。
眠いのに。
朝まで頑張って起きてゲットしたに
かわいそうに。
お母さんが屋根君に聞いてあげよっか。
よし。めちゃめちゃ盗めたぞ。世界ランク
10位だ。
はい。
あら。
あ、屋根す君のお母さん実は君だ。痛い。いいとこだったのに。
高がゲームでいいちいちめんどくさいな。はい、じゃあ返すわ。じゃあね。よしよしよしよしよし。屋根ちゃんキータ君泣かしたから今後はロブロックス禁止よ。え、お母さんが寝た後が勝負だ。秘密のゲーム部屋を作って。うお。
おお、バレないようにブロックスするぞ。よし、ゲーム部屋完成ブロックスし放題だ。行け行け行け行け行け。にゃんにゃんにゃにゃ。
屋根ちゃん、まさか夜中にゲームやってないわよね。う、最高。
よっしゃあ。1
番レア全然小さい。ゲットだ。
ちゃんと寝てるわよね。
うき、最高レアのブレインルットが集まっ
たぞ。よし、これで世界ランク1位だ。
あ、
なんだ、ちゃんと寝てるじゃないの。
あとは自分でゲームも作っちゃおうと。
これで世界配信と。あれ?もしかして俺の
ゲームバズってる?
あ、やべ。もう学校行かなきゃ。
聞いた。俺世界ランク
位になったよ。それに俺の作ったゲームが大ヒットしてるんだ。すごいでしょ。
へえ。僕の盗んだの謝ってくれなかったくてん。なんてな
んだ嫉妬してんのか。
挨拶するの。机が
3個と机が7
個ありました。さて景はいくつでしょう。
そういえば作ったゲーム小学生に遊んでもらいやすいように小学校の机合を使ったらみやすそうだな。
やす答えてみなさい。
あと失敗したら怖い先生に囲まれる演出とか面白そう。
おいおいのとか。
はい。じゃ、今日終わり。さようなら。
さようなら。
よし。じゃあみんなでちボールするいよ。
きた君、屋根君と喧嘩してるの?
ま、まあ。
屋根す君、ずっと寝てて元気ないし、かわいそうだから誘ってあげれば。
うん。分かったよ。屋根介、今日はごめん。一緒にどっちボルで遊ぼう。
うん。
あ、俺今日の面倒見なきゃいけなくて忙しくて。じゃあね。早く俺のゲームを改善してもっとバズらせるぞ。
よネ助君、弟の面倒を見なきゃいけないの大変だね。
やちゃんみはロブチョップスにはまりすぎて最近寝不足みたいな。
ロブロックスな。てかあいつ弟いたっけ?
確かに。
屋根す、今ロブロックスで遊んでる。イエー。
よし、いい感じだ。
あいつ嘘つきやがって。もう分かったぞ。分かったぞ。分かったぞ。分かったぞ。武器。めちゃめちゃゲバったぞ。これで
万円ゲット。あ、屋ねちゃんどこ行ったのかしら。靴もあるし。
アクティブレーザー10万人。今10
万人も俺のゲームに集まってるのか。
なんか屋根ちゃんやってるわね。
この匂いこっちね。行け行け行け。はい。盗んだ。はい。おつ。はい。お疲れ。イエイ。
おら。
おい、ロブロックス禁止って言ったよな。
でもアクティブーザー10
万人もいたし点てさも手に入たし俺めっちゃすごいんだよ。
何わけわかんねえこと言ってんだ。うわ。
俺のブレイノットのデータが全部なくなった。あんなに頑張ったのに。高がゲームで騒いでんじゃないわ。高がゲームでも大事だったんだよ。
みんな実はお母さんにゲーム破壊されて屋根すが来るなよ。
え?なんで
お前幼るって嘘ついてロブロックス遊ぶだよ。
このロブロックス
ごめん。
ゲームなんかよりも友達を大切にしないと嫌われちゃうよ。もうやめな。
そうだよね。もうロブロックスやめてみんなと遊ぶよ。
いいね。
そしたらみんなでロブロックスに課金して遊ぼうと思ってた。この稼いだ
100万円も捨よっかな。う
いやせっかくだしみんなでRob
ロックスに関係して遊ぼうぜ。
おし。
おいブロックス中毒になってるじゃんか。
2月21日土曜日18時からキータと2人
でロブロックスの生配信をします。みんな
見に来てね。